[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL AULET: I'm Bill Aulet.
I'm the managing director of the Martin
Trust Center for MIT Entrepreneurship.
We help hundreds of entrepreneurs
build great products and great teams.
These are the two most important
elements for a successful new venture.
We encourage our students
to have hackers, hustlers,
and hipsters on the team because
this hybrid vigor increases
their odds of producing
a truly great company.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERDIN BESHIMOV: I'm Erdin Beshimov.
I run an experimental
production group at MIT.
I'm also a teaching
fellow in this course.
Bill said that entrepreneurship
is about a team.
Well, so is online education.
We've brought together
Hollywood cinematographers,
great graphic designers, instructional
designers, MIT Entrepreneurship,
MIT faculty to create the Ferrari
of online education for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL AULET: When MIT first started
in the online education area,
we put people in the back of the room,
with cameras, to record the lectures.
PROFESSOR 1: This is 600, also known
as Introduction to Computer Science.
PROFESSOR 2: We're going to
start with non-linear analysis.
PROFESSOR 3: And what is not covered
today can and will be the on the exam.
BILL AULET: That was a good start.
But as time has gone on,
we can do so much more.
Today, with the advanced technologies,
as well as incorporating cinematography
techniques, we can
interweave powerful stories
with the lectures to give a vibrant
and energetic experience to people well
beyond the walls of MIT.
ERDIN BESHIMOV: This is transmedia
at its most experimental.
And it might be at its best.
We are taking one medium,
filmmaking, and taking it
into a whole different medium,
the internet and online education.
The goal of the course is to continue
the entrepreneurial revolution
around the world.
If at least one of you
starts a company and feels
like you're changing
the world and the people
that you're bringing to
your company, if they
feel like they're changing the
world, we have done our job.
Nothing will make us happier than that.
So welcome to the course.
And good luck.
NARRATOR: MIT began as
an institution designed
to serve the needs of our society at an
early stage of its industrialization.
If we are to produce the kind
of world required for the safety
and well-being of the human
beings who live in it,
we must build on this
international tradition.
[MUSIC PLAYING]